my very first job was paper round but my
first job were actually went and worked
somewhere was a farm shop in the middle
of nowhere and yeah it was a bit crazy
selling onions and like packing sacks of
potatoes everyone always asked me if I
was nervous and I actually wasn't
because I didn't expect anyone to watch
it so there was nothing really to be
nervous about I cried when I saw my book
for the first time it was just such an
achievement because I worked really hard
on it I think my first fashion fails
when I wore some really terrible flares
with the skirt sewn on top a guy from my
school called Sam Willis
hey Sam if you're watching
it was my Mulberry Taylor bag I actually
lived in a barn conversion in the
country
it sounds really glamorous but it
actually was not glamorous at all really
friendly I thought he was just a really
nice gentleman just Evita I was obsessed
with Evita it's hard to put into words
today has just been the best day when it
was all over I nearly kind of like cried
with happiness because not that it was
over but that it had happened and I feel
so lucky to have had such an amazing
team
way